the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC it is being reported that Russian
President Vladimir Putin is readying
nuclear weapons what does this mean can
we trust it but maybe most importantly
what is it actually like to theorize
about what would happen if such weapons
were to be Unleashed so let's start with
the beginning a number of not very good
sources and then some okay sources are
reporting things like what Newsweek is
reporting Russia primes nuclear bomb 12
times more powerful than that dropped on
Hiroshima now let's break down the
headline more powerful than that dropped
on Hiroshima this is a very common 21st
century headline the it's very common
that now the nukes that countries have
access to are more powerful than the one
that was dropped on Hiroshima so that
doesn't tell us too too much but let's
look into the details video of an
intercontinental ballistic missile on a
silo launcher has been released by
Russia's defense Ministry and widely
reported by the country's media in an
apparent warning to the West a Russian
tabloid newspaper reported that the yars
missile complex which was loaded in the
Kaluga region had a capacity 12 times
greater than the American bomb that
destroyed Hiroshima in 1945. the mass
circulation papers report outlined some
of the missile specifications including
a launch way to 46 000 tons which some
are disputing as possible as implausible
an operational range of up to 12 000
kilometers that can strike the us or
anywhere in Europe and a payload of up
to 500 kilo tons now is Putin doing this
and what might cause him to do something
like this we can't say with complete and
total certainty so I think it's maybe
more interesting and more relevant to
talk generally about what this would be
like what would it look like
geopolitically and in term terms of the
science of it if Russia launched a nuke
of roughly this size against the West
often we just say well it would be a
general nuclear winter nuclear Holocaust
but I find that it's better to be a
little more specific the exact outcomes
of what would happen if Russia were to
launch one of these nukes let's let's
put it at one for the time being as more
likely that it would be one rather than
a bunch just for the sake of discussion
uh the consequences would really depend
on the specific Target uh and and the
number of weapons used but the potential
consequences would likely include the
destruction of whatever city is hit and
the infrastructure of that City so
you're talking buildings you're talking
roads Bridges and power grids already
catastrophic but those are the primary
impacts then we have to talk about the
sort of like follow-on effects you then
would have contamination of large areas
with radiation
that has significant consequences in
terms of long-term health effects for
the survivors uh potentially making the
areas uninhabitable and of course the
impact that that would have on the
ability to grow food remember the
bridges are destroyed the roads are
destroyed so if you can't grow food
where do you bring food from if the
bridges and the and and the roads are
also destroyed so you can see how these
are compounding effects economic
disruption on a global scale trade and
financial markets would likely be
devastated a significant geopolitical
escalation would like likely happen it's
sort of an understatement I think the
question is to what extent and how
quickly does the West respond in kind
does this lead to a full-scale war
involving nuclear weapons which these
are these are just such dystopian
scenarios that it can be hard to think
about them uh sort of in Practical terms
and then of course the general increase
in likelihood that other countries would
use their own nuclear weapons and and a
global nuclear conflict that could
develop really important to understand
the catastrophic nature here I mean
think about just one item like to go
back to food supply
nuclear bombing would have a
catastrophic effect on the food supply
in the affected areas the explosion
itself would destroy Farmland crops
livestock food stores that exist so you
immediately have food shortages the
contamination of the environment with
radiation could make it difficult or
even impossible to grow crops to raise
animals in those affected areas
furthering the food shortages into long
term then you've got to bring food in
from somewhere else but the
infrastructure was destroyed as I
mentioned the roads the bridges the
ports so transporting food in becomes
difficult exacerbating those very
shortages and and so just to take one
area of food the use of a nuke could
devastate the food supply and leave lead
to widespread starvation so that's just
food that we're talking about how long
would areas be affected by a nuke the
effects of radiation on the environment
can last for years
and it can take a significant amount of
time before it would be safe to live in
an affected area
to to grow food in an effective area
affected area to raise animals it can
take a very long time and in some cases
effects can be what for the human
lifespan we would call permanent or
semi-permanent so we don't know what's
going on with Putin right now health
questions questions about his mental
state questions about what is the game
plan here with what's going on in
Ukraine and we have increasing but
isolated and not exquisitely well
sourced reports that nukes are being
readied we have to hope of course it
doesn't go in that direction and to the
extent that diplomacy can be used to
prevent that we should welcome it the
governor of Oregon has commuted all
death sentences for the 17 individuals
on death row in Oregon the governor is
against the death penalty and I think
that this is an absolutely fantastic
decision CNN reports Oregon governor
calls death penalty immoral
commute sentences for all 17 inmates on
debt on death row outgoing Oregon
governor Kate Brown is commuting the
sentences of all 17 people on death row
to life imprisonment without the
possibility of parole according to a
news release yesterday she said since
taking office in 2015 I have continued
Oregon's moratorium on executions
because the death penalty is both
dysfunctional and immoral today I am
commuting Oregon's death row so that we
will no longer have anyone serving a
sentence of death and facing execution
in this state she used executive
clemency powers to commute the sentences
it is set to take effect today now
important to understand about the death
penalty in Oregon generally as the
article says Oregon has executed two
people since the U.S Supreme Court
reinstated the death penalty in 1976 and
since Oregon reinstated the death
penalty in 1984 the most recent was in
1997. I think that this is a fantastic
decision
I'm against the death penalty I believe
we should all be against the death
penalty and there are so many reasons
some of which I will tell you right now
now I want to say up front
sometimes there are people who are
against the death penalty for three of
the reasons I'm going to mention and
they will say David that fourth reason
isn't very good it's sort of fallacious
actually
let's take them one at a time and I know
specifically what people are talking
about but let's take them one at a time
first of all
if we believe that human lives have
inherent value which is often part of
the justification for the death penalty
meaning it goes something like human
life has inherent value and so when you
take a life you are giving up your right
to live and therefore the state can or
should take your life intentionally if
we are against the intentional taking of
lives which have inherent value
then we can't say except when the person
has done a b or c at which point the
state should get involved in the
business of taking life nope doesn't
make sense the state should not be
involved in that and I am against it
secondly
there are wrongful convictions all the
time in our justice system and in
addition to there being innocent people
on death row there are also many
cognitively limited people on death row
and so because we can't possibly get it
right we can't accept as a society the
possibility of putting to death someone
who may be innocent now you could say
but David what if the system were
perfect and there were no one innocent I
would still be against it for the other
reasons that I'm mentioning so don't
just because one reason alone isn't
bulletproof don't say it's not a reason
the state shouldn't be taking lives and
there are innocent people on death row
and there are cognitively limited people
on death rope solving just one of those
things doesn't actually change anything
you can't undo
taking a life whereas if you imprison
someone and they're innocent there's at
least the chance of fixing it and
compensating them in the future
third it does not appear as though the
death penalty is an effective deterrent
to crime and that it is not actually
making Society safer it's it's beyond
the scope of this segment to look at
that uh but it's been widely studied and
so if it's not a deterrent then why are
we putting the state in the position of
obtaining the chemicals that we use
which sometimes work and sometimes take
hours it doesn't make any sense I also
don't think that the death penalty is
the harshest sentence for the offender
and what I mean by that is based on my
beliefs you put someone to death and the
lights go out and they're suffering or
living with the consequences of their
actions ends if you put someone in
prison without the possibility of parole
they're gonna sit there for however long
they live living with the reality of
what they did and that they now live in
a box forever now I am not one to say
that there should be extra punishments
like for example prison rape I'm against
that those are indications that our
prison system is unable to keep inmates
safe but I do believe that turning the
lights off for lack of a better term is
a less harsh punishment than making
someone sit in prison for the rest of
their life so if your desire is the
worst possible punishment and experience
for the offender it's life in prison
without parole and then if your concerns
are Financial if you care about money
it's cheaper to do prison without the
possibility of parole because in our
system uh individuals on death row have
significant access to appeals now some
people will say get rid of the appeals
no no we need those appeals because
there are so many innocent people on
death row so there is no reason to
before the death penalty and I think
what Kate Brown is doing is absolutely
fantastic and I'm glad to see that she
did it
the real climate change risks over the
next 10 years who's telling you the
truth about them there is so much
discussion about
we've got a 10 or 12 years left before
total climate disaster there is no
greater believer than me in the climate
science believe I accept the climate
science to say I believe in it is not
even the right term because the climate
science is what it is regardless of
belief I accept climate science I
believe we have to act and I believe we
have to act now I also think it's
important to be accurate and sober
rather than hyperbolic about the real
risks over the next 10 years so let's
talk about what those are there are some
risks that are overblown at least when
thinking about the next decade one of
the most important risks of climate
change over the next 10 years is the
potential for more extreme weather
events and we have been seeing some of
them heat waves which are deadly
droughts which can affect food
production floods which can create and
spread disease and cause all sorts of
other problems the negative impacts of
the extreme weather events as a result
of climate change are very real they can
damage infrastructure they can destroy
crops they can lead to death and
affect human health directly
that's a real risk and it is now and it
is a real risk over the next decade
another significant risk from climate
change is the potential for sea level
rise that's a real risk that could have
significant impacts on Coastal
communities already and over the next 10
years sea level goes up it can displace
people it can cause damage to buildings
and infrastructure their Economic
Consequences as well as social
consequences and the unrest that would
happen if large populations have to
start moving because where they live is
underwater that's a that's a real risk
now and over the next 10 years on the
other hand let me give you some examples
of less important risks particularly
over the next 10 years food production
is one often our our food production
will be destroyed by climate change and
soon is thrown out there the best
science we have right now does not
actually point that way slight global
warming
could actually be beneficial for
agriculture doesn't mean we want it but
it me just it is what it is it could be
beneficial slightly higher temperatures
and slightly higher carbon dioxide
levels in the atmosphere could actually
improve crop growth and there are
studies that have shown that under
certain conditions
when you have a little bit higher
temperature a little more CO2
you can even increase crop yields like
for corn and wheat but also you can
increase the land area on Earth where
food can be produced on average so right
now you know in the future you could
have a feedback loop that maybe would
would point to it being bad for food
production but that's not actually one
that is of concern right now and that's
the best science that we have
um another example would be the
potential for slight changes in global
temperature now it's really important to
understand what I'm saying and what I'm
not saying here a rise in global
temperature can have negative impacts
but over the next 10 years the changes
from average global temperature are
likely to be extraordinarily small or
non-existent now distinguish
temperature is being slightly higher on
average is different than
acute weather events including heat
waves which absolutely can be deadly but
just it being a little bit warmer on
average is not actually the disaster
over the next 10 years that some believe
that it will be
um some folks are also concerned about
the potential for climate change to
cause widespread loss of biodiversity
and accelerate the extinction of certain
species it is absolutely true that in a
feedback loop climate change can have
negative impacts on biodiversity the
overall risks are considered very low
right now compared to other human
activities like the fact that we're
destroying habitats by clearing entire
forests as one example and polluting the
air okay so the climate change component
effect on biodiversity over the next 10
years much smaller than a lot of these
other things that we are doing so what's
the takeaway here the takeaway is it
would be best to have two things happen
number one
we talk about the risks in the realist
scientific terms and if we have a list
of 10 possible disasters but four of
them really aren't acute concerns right
now let's focus on the six that are
and number two let's actually act on the
ones that are the biggest risks because
that's going to have it's sort of like
the lowest hanging fruit in the impact
that we have if you're interested in in
this discussion the book precipice by
Toby ORD discusses a lot of what I'm
talking about uh in pretty significant
detail make sure that you are subscribed
on the YouTube channel help us get to 2
million YouTube subscribers it could
happen sooner than later with your help
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
the David packman show is an audience
and community supported program we
really couldn't do what we do if it
weren't for your support and the best
way to support the work we do is through
the membership program you can sign up
at joinpakman.com it takes under a
minute for someone with average mobile
phone or computer skills you'll get the
daily bonus show an extra show produced
just for you as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
available hours before the show is
published and very soon we will have our
next members only Town Hall which I
would love for you to participate in
sign up at joinpakman.com use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
discount I am going to show you right
now why later let's do it now how Tucker
Carlson turns reality into conspiracy
theory and this is a really great
example you know I've told you before
very often right-wing talking points and
or conspiracy theories start with a
kernel of truth there's a kernel of
Truth somewhere even if it's sometimes
sort of hard to find and it is
fundamental if you want to be an
informed consumer of political and news
media think for yourself be able to to
figure things out for yourself
to understand the mechanism that I'm
going to show you here in this clip
Tucker Carlson talks about the signing
ceremony that took place yesterday at
the White House
for the bill that
codifies gay marriage into law even
though it doesn't really all it says is
states have to recognize gay marriages
but doesn't actually say states have to
Grant marriage licenses to gay or
lesbian couples we talked about the bill
earlier in the week I was invited to go
to the White House for this event just
too short they literally invited me the
day before uh I just couldn't make it on
that short notice because I had to be
here with all of you doing a show who do
they think I am but in any case they had
this event and Tucker Carlson starts
talking about the event but look at how
quickly he takes the kernel of Truth and
expands it into an absurd conspiracy
theory
it's pretty interesting when you think
about it so this is a bill signing
affirming the legality legalizing once
again gay marriage which most people
support in this country should be able
to get married if they love each other
yeah they should that's fine okay so
that is true it was an event to sign
that bill the bill is about affirming
gay marriages even though it doesn't
guarantee them but like the event
happened that's what the bill is for so
far it's okay let's continue not that
controversial a point at this stage
but here's Joe Biden using that
opportunity to promote gender affirming
care for kids and of course that means
the sexual mutilation of children
cutting the breasts off 15 year olds
sterilizing them for life with chemicals
now remember we looked at the numbers
cutting off the breasts of 15 year olds
understand they've already had to modify
their talking point on this first they
were talking about cutting the breasts
off of prepubescent girls prepubescent
girls don't really have breasts to cut
off so then they started going into well
these are minors are they 18 or 17 and a
half or 50. so they're just modifying
the exact figures to try to make it
plausible but this really isn't
happening and there are of course in a
country of 331 million people you can
find examples of everything and often
for good reasons and different reasons
that we may not even know because of
medical privacy in particular cases but
he's expanding this into oh well that
this is celebrating the event which was
about affirming gay marriage is about
celebrating double mastectomies for
gender affirming reasons on 15 year old
girls which basically doesn't happen
that's what Boston Children's Hospital
and many other hospitals have been doing
puberty blockers have fun with
osteoporosis when you're 30. okay now
that I don't know about I don't know
about any potential link between puberty
blockers and osteoporosis not really the
Crux of this discussion though so why
would Joe Biden be promoting that apart
from the fact certain special interest
groups want him to okay so there's
another idea which is part of the reason
Biden is promoting this stuff which he
isn't and which barely ever happens is
that it's the money there are moneyed
interests that want the so-called
mutilation of children we're off the
deep end now into conspiracy world
again this was supposed to be about gay
marriage and it was but here you have
Joe Biden president United States
purportedly pushing child sexual
mutilation now we are very off the deep
end from where we started here and it's
important to understand how these things
happen outside of the media right to not
Tucker because this is a for-profit show
but outside of the media just among the
population
sometimes reality gets turned into a
conspiracy theory
sort of accidentally it can happen when
people are trying to make sense of
something that's complicated or there
are unfamiliar events people don't have
all the information and they start
filling in gaps and they add
interpretations or they add assumptions
or they assume the worst and put that in
there and that can really distort your
picture of what happens Sandy Hook is a
great example of that you can often also
get into conspiracy bill when people are
looking to explain events that are
difficult to understand or that go
against their beliefs or that point to a
much more dangerous and unpredictable
world than people would like to believe
we have so you fill it in with a
conspiracy to say there wasn't
Randomness it wasn't random it was
planned that's not what Tucker is doing
Tucker is doing a show where he is
deliberately taking something completely
benign and uncontroversial an event
signing this a firm affirmation of gay
marriage bill and turning it into a
conspiracy theory which is the type of
thing his audience is already expecting
to hear Biden affirming gay marriage
there's got to be more to that there
must be evil lurking somewhere and when
you hear something like this there are
really simple steps you can take to
evaluate it and this may be our next
white paper quite frankly examine the
evidence look at the evidence that
exists and consider is this evidence
credible and reliable is it based in
fact is it speculation is it hearsay
start there
are there alternative explanations that
are not nefarious based on the credible
evidence that we have look at the
sources who's presenting The Conspiracy
Theory do they have a motive to present
a conspiracy theory rather than what is
suggested by the facts that we actually
know for sure check for confirmation
bias is the person giving you the theory
or are you looking for evidence that
supports a certain conclusion already
and ignoring evidence that contradicts
it confirmation bias we've talked about
that look for independent verification
check to see has The Conspiracy Theory
been identity independently verified by
others have other people or
organizations looked at the evidence and
come to the same conclusions or are
there other conclusions that folks have
come to and lastly you always think
critically does it pass the sniff test
does it make any sense is it logical and
consistent with other things that I know
about the world aside from being
supported by the evidence that's the
framework and it might make for for a
great white paper and by the way more
than 3 000 people have now downloaded
the free guide to having political
arguments with people
davidpackman.com guide It's genuinely
free it's a free guide it's available
download it at davidpackman.com guide
we're continuing our look at whether or
not Fox News is abandoning Donald Trump
in 2024 the answer seems to continue to
be they're not abandoning him yet but
they've got an ejection an ejection seat
and they could pull the lever at any
time if it looks like things are going
to go the direction of Ron DeSantis
here's yet another example Stuart Varney
interviewed Mitch McConnell's wife
Elaine Chao Elaine Chao was attacked by
Donald Trump for her ethnicity now
multiple times he's referred to her as
Coco chow and what is interesting about
this interview is that Stuart Varney
says I mean months too late but Stuart
Varney says we were all appalled here at
Fox News when Trump spoke about you that
way not sounding very Fox News like
let's take a listen I want to talk about
inflation in a moment but first former
president Trump attacked you on the
grounds of your ethnicity I wonder if
you'd like to take this moment to
respond
well the President says many things I
don't make a point of responding to uh
his comments okay I'll leave it right
there we were all appalled at what he
said and uh it's up to you what you say
in response thank you very much we were
all appalled by what he said
so this is kind of interesting there
there are people making too much of this
you know the first thing is if everyone
at Fox News was appalled when Trump said
this about Elaine Chao in what was the
exact date the very beginning of October
uh it's almost the end of December now
so they hid they kept to themselves how
appalled they were about what Trump said
until mid-December uh so if they were
indeed appalled they they were not super
eager to make it known but this is yet
another one of those you don't really
have to read further into it uh than at
face value which is Fox News is
maintaining a certain distance from
Trump under notice that even since
announcing that he was running in 2024 I
don't believe Trump had like a serious
interview on Fox News I don't even know
if he's appeared at all Fox News is
keeping a respectful distance to Trump
while continuing to have pro-trump and
anti-trump voices from the right on the
channel Fox News doesn't know the
direction it's going to go we know that
the murdochs would prefer someone other
than Trump be the Republican nominee and
ultimately president and they're just
leaving themselves that possibility open
it's not the biggest deal but they just
want to be prepared with an escape hatch
if indeed the tide truly turns against
Trump that's what's going on here let's
not make more of it than it is but it is
something that that's the way Fox News
is approaching the 2024 primary so far
we'll have all of these clips that I
played on our Instagram which you can
find by searching Instagram for
davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
well Florida Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis fresh off of his big win to
re-election in the 2022 midterms has
announced an investigation into
covid vaccines I know I know Ron
DeSantis seems to be going fully
anti-vax we're going to talk about why
he also went on Fox News to attack covet
vaccines but first and foremost holding
a press event yesterday wherein he
announced in conjunction with the
Supreme Court of Florida they will
empanel a grand jury
sounds pretty serious huh to investigate
vaccine wrongdoing in Florida I I know
guys I know it's Bonkers what's going on
let's take a listen to what DeSantis had
to say because in Florida you know it is
against the law to mislead and to
misrepresent particularly when you're
talking about the efficacy of a drug we
see just the other uh just recently
Florida got 3.2 billion through legal
action against those responsible for the
opioid crisis and so it's not like this
is something that's unprecedented so
today I'm announcing a petition with the
Supreme Court of Florida to empanele a
Statewide grand jury to investigate any
and all wrongdoing in Florida with
respect to covid-19 vaccines and we how
powerful how principled
anticipate that we will get the approval
for that uh that will be something that
will be impaneled most likely in the
Tampa Bay Area uh and that will come
with legal processes that will be able
uh to get more information and to bring
legal accountability for those who
committed misconduct yeah now listen
there's two sides to this one side is
it seems as though Florida may have
committed the misconduct in their
opposition and attempt to tear down the
vaccines which I will get to in a moment
but the investigation really should be
of those people now you might remember
Florida involved in all sorts of hijinks
with the vaccine there was the woman who
was putting together that panel to
provide covet information
uh about hospitalizations
Etc she was fired that was an insane
incident which should be investigated
they have this uh State Surgeon General
or head of Department of Public Health
Dr latapo or ladapo who regularly puts
out covet and covet vaccine
disinformation as a mouthpiece for the
state that should be investigated but
that's not what they want to investigate
this is a point in the pandemic
where cases are again going up
the hospitalizations are
disproportionately the elderly the
deaths are disproportionately the
elderly we are in flu season the numbers
are not good for a group that is over
represented in Florida Florida on
average having a significantly older
population than many other states
DeSantis should be saying hey get your
bivalent boosters because we need the
protection right now but instead he
announces an investigation into vaccine
wrongdoing the wrongdoing is the
anti-vaxx people the pharmacists who
deliberately spoiled vaccines and the VA
the pharmacist who didn't really
vaccinate people pretended to but didn't
actually vaccinate people the
chiropractor who offered bogus medical
exemptions uh to be unvaccinated to
remain unvaccinated fraudulently and
just to anybody who wanted such an
exemption the people who spread the
disinformation online some of whom work
for the the State of Florida that's the
wrong doing we all know exist but that's
not what Ron DeSantis wants to
investigate he after this event
went on Fox News
and that's a whole other aspect to this
which I want to talk about and then we
will sort of uh speculate on why now and
why this and we'll get to that in a
moment after proudly announcing that the
State of Florida would investigate covet
vaccine wrongdoing recently re-elected
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis went of
course to Fox news on Fox News he was
interviewed by Laura Ingram and he is
now going full anti-vaxx I believe this
has to do with the potential Republican
presidential primary run against Donald
Trump I will explain that to you in a
moment but here is Ron DeSantis going
full anti-vaxx with Laura Ingram last
night to learn today and hearing again
these voices many of them suppressed or
people ostracized over the last few
years
well Laura like anything I mean you take
an m r a shot and the way to view mnra
mnra that doesn't sound quite right it
is okay what are the benefits and what
are the drawbacks yes and it seems like
our medical establishment never wanted
to be honest with people uh about the
potential drawbacks and so you showed a
clip from Dr latapo down here in Florida
and the analysis that he's done with
people particularly young men who've
taken the MRNA shots we of course had
remember that that analysis was not on
actual Florida Department of Health
letterhead it was completely unsigned
ladapo published it and it was based on
cherry-picked out of context inaccurate
information I can't re-debunk that
quote it's not even a study it's a paper
I don't even know what to call it that
opinion piece I can't redo all of that
right now but we have a dedicated
segment about that it was not it was
bogus Witnesses talk about their
experience and how are we in a situation
yes Florida we ban vaccine passports
almost two years ago we banned the shot
mandates for jobs and saved a lot of
people's jobs nevertheless throughout
our country you still have hundreds of
universities in other states that are
still mandating these boosters on these
college kids when any type of
cost-benefit analysis would say the
benefit from them taking the shot as you
as you alluded to it doesn't prevent
them from getting infected or spreading
it anyways the benefit is minuscule but
as Joe latapo and other Studies have
shown you know there is a risk for doing
it so why can't our medical
establishment acknowledge that why the
deception why have they continued to do
this for now I two years I have to tell
you
I don't know what he's talking about in
the sense that it seems widely known is
anyone covering up that these new
vaccines don't prevent the spread and
they don't appear to prevent infection
but the idea is to protect you from a
really serious case I would love it
remember I had coveted last week I would
love it if the vaccine did protect me
completely
it didn't but I felt really sick for 28
hours it seems plausible and backed by
the science that I had 28 hours of
feeling really sick rather than three
days five days whatever the case may be
on average remember with one person you
can never say because you either are
vaccinated when you get coveted or you
don't
that it was shortened dramatically
and it did not get more serious because
of the vaccine I mean it seems to me
everybody's been upfront about that
since the vaccines with the new variants
stopped preventing infection
it would be great for it to be better
but the idea that there's huge
wrongdoing here it does not seem based
on the facts now why is DeSantis doing
this
DeSantis believes this is an issue he
can use to beat Trump
the Maga base
is anti-vaxx
but Trump says I did a great thing by
getting these vaccines but it's up to
you whether you get it but you should
but you shouldn't have to and the Maga
base disagrees with Trump they often
will boo Trump when he talks about the
vaccines
DeSantis correctly perceives this is a
wedge that could be uh put between Trump
and his base to desantis's benefit
if DeSantis chooses to run the problem
is that the calculation might work in
the primary and not work in the general
and what I mean by that is the vast
majority of the public supports vaccines
and taking an anti-vaccine position in
the primary that you then can't run away
from in the general because at the end
of the day if if DeSantis runs and he
goes anti-vaxx in the primary he'll just
stop doing that when it gets to the
general and pretend it never happened
but it may be difficult to run away from
that position in the general and that
could actually damage Ron DeSantis this
is all speculative
since the scientist hasn't actually
announced that he's running for anything
yet although every sign seems to be
pointing in that direction after the
break we will talk about a new poll as
well as why 24 could end up being a
disaster for Trump if DeSantis does
choose to run that'll be after the break
but in the immediate DeSantis going
anti-vaxx it's a calculated move I don't
personally believe DeSantis believes any
of the stuff he's saying I just don't
knowing as much as I know about DeSantis
but he's trying to use it to set up this
wedge to try to drive Mega voters away
from Trump and potentially towards him
if he decides to run for president
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show as we wait
to find out whether Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis will or won't throw his hat
into the ring to try to be the
Republican Presidential nominee I want
to go through the most likely reasons
why Donald Trump's 2024 run could be a
complete and total disaster now before
we jump into the reasons remember that
since his announcement which was really
low energy people trying to walk out of
the ballroom at Mar-A-Lago as the
announcement was still going on one of
the lowest energy presidential
announcements I've ever seen Trump has
barely left his house for the month
since the announcement everything that's
going on is strange new polling is very
bad for Trump and we'll talk about that
in a moment so that's sort of like the
the preface but I also want to add to
the preface no matter what I say here
we're not counting Trump out he
shouldn't be counted out this was a
mistake that was made in 2016. we still
don't know what's going to happen as Joe
Walsh told us yesterday
for now Trump is still at the top of the
party however there are things that are
different this time around we have a
former president who lost and is now
running again after not being president
for four years those are not common
circumstances in addition that former
president who's running again is losing
in early polling to a guy who hasn't
even announced that he's running for
anything Rhonda Sanders so this is
really an unprecedented situation now I
get emails from people saying David I
generally am hearing oh this could be
bad for Trump this could go bad what are
the most prep present I guess I would
say risks of how this could go poorly
okay let's go through them in no
particular order number one
Trump might and it appears that he will
face significant opposition from within
the Republican party some Republicans
see Trump's candidacy as we like the
policy I know that's hilarious it's like
what policy we like the policy but Trump
is divisive Trump is damaging to the
Republican party's chances of winning we
don't think he can win and this is part
of what former Republican Congressman
Joe Walsh told us yesterday they like
trumpism
but they just don't know that Trump
could win they're just not sure about it
so that's number one and the early signs
from the polling wherein Ron DeSantis is
already beating Trump in many polls even
though he hasn't announced is a sign
that indeed there may be significant
dissent from within the Republican Party
number two
I know that we always say this and it
never happens Trump does anything he
wants and then still you know becomes
president whatever Trump's past conduct
including the sort of culmination of
multiple impeachments inciting the
Insurrection at the U.S Capitol
Etc
May acutely weaken him and make him
vulnerable to attacks from others from
within and outside of his party in a way
that was not the case during prior
elections because in 2016 was before the
Insurrection and 2020 was before the
Insurrection we don't know to what
degree that is going to impact uh the
campaign and how it will affect Donald
Trump
three
um Trump's statements and policies and
inflammatory rhetoric immigration
Mexicans the anti-semitic stuff now it's
conceivable that it will alienate not
the Maga base but the types of folks
that are more in the middle the
independence the I'm a republican but I
don't love Trump but I'd probably vote
for him except maybe now it's just
gotten Beyond The Pale we know that
there's anti-Semitism and xenophobia and
racism in the Republican party but it's
not complete in total and that may
impact Trump if Trump decides to go
fully steam full steam ahead on that in
his uh 2024 run and he seems like maybe
he is the rhetoric that he has been
focusing on at rallies when he was still
having them was anti-trans uh
anti-immigrant uh ridiculing people from
all sorts of different walks of life so
that is something that could have an
impact legal challenges this is another
layer to this Trump May well get
indicted there are ongoing
investigations into Financial dealings
there's the possibility of criminal
charges there are civil suits all of
this stuff could number one be a
distraction from the campaign
but maybe more importantly
it really could undermine his
credibility as a candidate how is a
republican electorate that already seems
to have cooled on Trump going to react
if the guy is under indictment and being
prosecuted are they going to say well we
should go to somebody less controversial
with fewer encumbrances or is it going
to activate them and get them to say
they're going to indict my president
I'll show them by supporting Trump it's
unpredictable it's an open question I
don't think we'll know if and until it
happens and then there's the financial
aspect to this uh Trump has grifted
donors for a very long time
um but he may struggle to fundraise he
may have real problems fundraising uh
from certain donors particularly donors
who would be hesitant to contribute to
Trump because of the potential legal
problems uh people unwilling to con
contribute to Trump because they'd
prefer someone else like a DeSantis and
just want to wait to see does de Santa
say is going to run and that could
weaken Trump early so it is very
difficult to predict what will happen
it's also all starting so early
potentially even ill-advised that it's
starting so early in the sense that you
know Trump seemed to think it was better
for him legally to announce early even
though Merritt Garland of others have
said it's really not going to make a
difference we're going to do what we
have to do but these are the potential
reasons that Trump May struggle the
obstacles he may face and a lot of it is
going to come down to does Ron DeSantis
actually run for this thing the latest
polling is unbelievable for Rhonda
Santos
shocking new 24 Republican primary poll
shows Trump imploding DeSantis at 56
Trump at 33.
this is stunning stuff BBC article
Trump's conservative base deserting him
for DeSantis most republican-leaning
voters would prefer Florida's governor
over Donald Trump as their 2024
Presidential nominee according to a
survey by a 56 to 33 margin dear God
conservative voters picked Ron DeSantis
over Trump
the Suffolk University USA Today poll
also found Joe Biden has a higher
approval than Donald Trump it follows
mixed results I'll say for Trump
backhand that it's in midterm elections
DeSantis outposts Trump not only among
the general electorate but also among
these republican-leaning voters who have
been the former president's base
Republicans and conservative
Independents increasingly want trumpism
without Trump
also interesting the poll released
Tuesday recorded only a 30 approval for
Trump compared with 46 for Biden the
survey also found over 60 percent of
Voters would prefer neither Trump nor
Biden stand in the 2024 race so let's
talk through a few aspects of this first
question which we should all be asking
how valuable is a presidential primary
poll
roughly 18 or 19 months before the bulk
of that primary right we're 23 months
from the 2024 election but these are
primary polls so we're dealing with
something that will take place over that
summer so it's more like 19 months away
how valuable is it a poll today uh it's
limited it's quite limited the general
answer is 19 months out
can't predict how the political
landscape will change between now and
then things can happen external to the
candidates that shift support one way or
the other uh the economy may change we
don't yet officially know that Joe Biden
is even running DeSantis hasn't actually
said he's running we don't know legally
what is coming for Donald Trump
International events shifts in public
opinion scandals we just don't know
there's all of these things that make
this polling extraordinarily premature
that being said the most important
takeaway here is zoom out Trump has been
the president and is the de facto leader
of the Republican Party Ron DeSantis
isn't even running
and here is a good poll I'm a good
pollster
that says DeSantis is up more than 20
points over Trump among the primary
electorate that's not the type of thing
you can easily dismiss at least as far
as pointing to the picture today
now
what about Trump what is he doing or
saying about this Trump posted an
alternative poll to truth sensual uh
interactive polls IA polls 2022 Politico
morning consult which has Trump winning
by 18. so there are definitely other
polls out there that are not bad for
Donald Trump
um
at what point does a presidential
primary poll
accurately reflect who's likely to be
the eventual winner
in the months leading up to the primary
you know the polling can fluctuate
particularly in a very contested primary
with many candidates the polling can
fluctuate April May and then typically
June July of the election year I'm not
not even talking about 23 I'm talking
about 24. June July is when it really
starts to become definitive and so these
are very important early signals what
they really mean about what will take
place in a year and a half we really
don't know but if you're Trump you'd
rather be winning as the former
president than losing to a guy who
hasn't even said that he's running we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P take a listen to this
voicemail from a guy who's just throwing
out all the right-wing Mega red meat
listen to this
and I'm going to say he gave his pack
boys a better
Bay tomorrow what he's saying is David
packboy is a beta male thank you
and uh
okay well vote for the guy go ahead
Jesse Lee Peterson's an alpha Mill and
he's innocent and you know Jesse Lee
Peterson hasn't to say Jesse Peterson is
innocent
people have come out and said Jesse Lee
Peterson's gay
I don't know that innocent is
necessarily the right term yes he's
accused of making advances but the the
term innocent is a weird term to use and
Joe Biden Hunter Biden prison 2023.
that's a bet I would be willing to take
I am not a betting man
but if someone wants to bet even odds do
hunter or Joe Biden end up in prison in
2023 I will take the no on whatever
Stakes you've got later yeah later uh
this is pretty significant brain rot but
unfortunately at least some of these
people vote it's important we all be
registered and we all participate I have
something super exciting to announce to
you
next Friday December 23rd we have never
done something like this before we're
going to be doing our end of the year
membership Drive oh David but you've
done that before Oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
as bad no no no this is different okay
our end of the year membership Drive
it'll be a one day event Friday December
23. it'll be beautifully timed right
before Christmas and during Hanukkah
it's going to be fantastic okay it's
gonna be really really good open to
everybody whatever you celebrate or
don't celebrate one day membership Drive
the first month's payment
for people who sign up on that day using
the special coupon code
is going to be donated and then matched
and doubled and we are going to be doing
this through give directly which
actually gives cash to people in extreme
poverty widely known now the best way to
really build industry and community and
allow people to determine for themselves
how best to improve their lives you
don't send shoes you give cash okay so
this is super super exciting Friday
December 23 it's going to be a
membership drive with a great discount
code so you can get a membership but
then that first payment if you pay
monthly it'll be your first payment if
you pay yearly will take a 12th of it
your first month's membership payment
we're not keeping we will donate and
then double it okay I have no idea
whether this will do well or whether it
won't we've never done anything like it
before but I would love for you to
participate it's really easy get on my
mailing list at davidpackman.com
just get on the mailing list
Friday December 23rd you'll get an email
telling you here's the coupon code you
sign up you get the membership we donate
that first payment and double it donate
and double double
unbelievable stuff excited to do it last
thing we've got a great bonus show for
you today we're going to talk about the
new plan to ban tick tock the plan to
ban Tick Tock in the US secondly we've
learned that Brett Kavanaugh hangs out
with Matt Gates why what are they doing
is it appropriate it's not and we will
talk about the pandemic border entry
limits on migrants being set to end next
week what are the implications what are
the uh speculations all of that and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com and get instant access
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpakman.com NYC